I was
supposed to go in the very first
session and I had a plan and that plan
was I'd do Ted I'd see
Vancouver I'd chill out I'd get this
thing done then I'd relax I'd listen to
other people's speeches rob their best
ideas bring them home and sound
incredibly incredibly brainy and then
your man Chris Rings me last weekend he
says you know that last thing the first
thing why don't you go last I'm like oh
man and it brought to mind the words of
that great
American
philosopher Mike
Tyson who set of plans everybody has a
plan until they get a punch in the
face and of course you know doing the
last gig of Ted
it's not about the pressure that's not
the problem the pressure isn't the
problem the problem is the
sobriety but the speeches have been
amazing right and if I could kind of
encapsulate them all it's really been
about as far as I can see the pace of
change and what that's doing to us
demographically politically socially
economically extraordinary stuff and I'd
now like to quote
from a great
liberal Democrat a friend of
Ted Vladimir
Lennon who said of change and crisis
that there are decades when nothing
happens and there are
weeks when decades happen and we're
living through those weeks you get that
feeling and it's really difficult to
know where to start to think about these
how do how do you this stuff now if I
was an American Economist or a Canadian
Economist or God forbid an English
Economist actually the nice thing is
they're not good at economics anymore
it's so beautiful isn't
it praise the Lord praise the
Lord but I'd come here armed with the
tools of my trade you know that the
graphs and the charts the mats and all
that good stuff but I'm an Irish
Economist so I'm only going to come here
armed with some lines and some verses of
poetry yeah there thank you very much
the poets in the corner were a small
minority no were perfectly formed now I
want to talk to you about a poem that
was written in
1919 called the second coming by WB
Yates our national poet and the fasc F
inting thing about crisis so 1919 100
odd years ago the fascinating thing
about crisis is that every
generation feels that their crisis is
the big one we're kind of narcissistic
about it right but every generation
experiences crisis every generation our
parents our grandparents they all did
how we deal with the crisis is the
definitive issue for Our Generation so
Yates is
sitting in Dublin 1919 he's trying to
make sense of the world right his world
is changing rapidly the German Empire is
over the Austrian Empire is over the
Ottoman Empire is over Ireland has
declared a war of Independence against
Britain which if you were a betting man
you wouldn't really give us not our side
you wouldn't have given us good odds and
the Yates is trying to figure out not
just what is happening but what is
likely to happen and he writes these
words and just listen to them and
imagine they were written
now the second coming turning and
turning in the widening gu the Falcon
cannot hear the falconer Things Fall
Apart the center cannot
hold mere Anarchy is loosed on the world
a blood dimmed tide is loosed and
everywhere the procession of innocence
is
drowned the best lack all conviction the
worst are full of passionate
intensity just let those words
lie Things Fall
Apart the best
people lack conviction the worst are
full of passionate intensity now this is
Yates writing 100 years ago and the
historical Rhythm and repetition is
clear I think to all of us but what
really interests me as an economist is
the contrast between what Yates the poet
was saying back then and what all the
economists the people who were employed
to think about the future were saying so
Yates
said the center will not hold three
years after he wrote this three years
three to four years musolini was in
power in Italy Stalin was on the
ascendancy in the Soviet Union and a
little small prepossessing man with a
mustache called Adolf Hitler had just
orchestrated a pooch in
Munich Yates was
right Yates was right and what were all
the economists saying back then the
people who were paid to think about the
future they were all saying oh don't
worry we'll go back to the gold stand
not all the vast majority we will go
back to the gold
standard we trade again Germany would
pay all its reparations and the first
world war will have been the war to end
all
wars how wrong could they
be so what's always bugged me is why did
the poet get things so right at a
Tipping Point and the economists get
things so wrong and I believe it is
because the poet the artist the musician
these types of people give themselves at
a Tipping Point the permission to think
unconventionally they see the world
differently do we value the
unconventional thinker do we and maybe
the best way to answer that question is
to go all the way back to school to the
place we begin to learn now just bring
yourselves
back to your school days remember
yourself at 13 just remember the person
you were you I remember the the
classroom I remember the teachers I
remember the building I remember the
break I remember everything I remember
the sports day I remember the whole
thing in fact there's a gang of five of
us whove hung around since you're in
school and those five Lads I was in
school with spent the entire of our
school years looking out the window they
just didn't get it they just didn't get
school at all and they've gone on to
have incredibly successful lives in
their own individual
ways but their intelligence their form
of intelligence was not recognized and
as we get older we realize the world is
full of various different intelligences
but back in school we only really
recognized one type of intelligence and
that was like the little kid who could
come in big wide-eyed kid right it come
in could absorb all this information
into his head or her head it open some
sort of weird compartment stuff it all
in stuff stuff stuff stuff stuff it all
in and then in early June when the
weather gets good in Ireland and I
presume it's the same all over the place
except for Vancouver right like be Jus
right that was the type of intelligence
we rewarded it's like getting a prize
for being a walking filing cabinet
right that's one intelligence it is an
intelligence but it's only one type of
intelligence and what about all the
other kids over here kids who didn't get
it all those other kids they weren't not
only recognized they intelligence was
smed
humiliated and
belittled my daughter is dyslexic she
hated every single day of school and as
a result of this system we have a
strange thing in our society where there
are thousands of incredibly clever
people who left school feeling stupid
but the coroller is also the case there
are many actually
quite stupid
people you know where I'm going who left
school feeling very very clever and
those kids when they were really good
kids they used to get the best marks in
school used to have a little star over
them right and of course the teacher
told them they were clever and the
priests and the nuns told them they were
clever and of course their mommy told
them they were clever right if you want
to get a sense of an Irish mommy an
Irish mommy is the sort of mother that
makes an American soccer mom look
unambitious I know I have one right I am
the son of a retired school teacher if
anybody else in the room is the son or
daughter of a school teacher we can form
a self-help group later on to deal with
our trauma right but those sort of kids
you know those sort of kids they do
extremely extremely well in school and
they do very very well in college and
then they get on to because they do very
very well they get on to you know the
The Graduate training programs and they
join the big Banks and they join the big
firms and they they they they they join
insurance companies they join the
consultancies and they're on the fast
track they're on the fast track
career-wise and something weird happens
as their career
progresses we like to think that we
surround ourselves with people who think
differently but we don't there's
something called confirmation bias we
actually surround ourselves with people
who confirm our biases and how this
works in instit
utions is the following we end up
employing people who think like us right
and like if you imagine an interview
process so the person goes into the
interview and there's a clever person
over here and there's a clever person
over no no you're clever oh GE no no
you're clever you're amazing oh you got
that great oh my God you went to that
University oh my God you're clever no
you're clever that's amazing I read that
paper you WR you're clever amazing just
f it just have the
job so the interview becomes by the way
I said fact
there
not the other
word Fe is a sort of a linguistic
version of a white lie okay it's used at
home now what actually happens is the
interview process just becomes like a
Tinder for people who can do Algebra
okay so they all go into the institution
and then what you get you get group
think because everyone's thinking the
same way and of course because these
people have always been the clever kids
with the right answer you know they
Define themselves so I'm the person with
right answer and what happens when
you're the person who's always is the
right answer it's very hard to be
wrong right so it breeds a sort of an
overconfidence and we know that
overconfidence and overconfident people
can really overestimate their
competences at critical moments the
thing comes from a thing called Dunning
Krueger in Psychology it's great story a
fellow goes into to rob a bank right in
America somewhere I think Pittsburgh
down there somewhere down there over
there right
someone in the '90s lad goes into rubber
Bank okay he runs into the bank the
security cards he's got no mask no
ballot laava no nothing right the
security camera looks at him and he
Winks at it and he Winks again a big
smile Hi how are you goes in holds up
the bank robs the thing goes off coppers
come in look at the
Securities see the gezer he just waves
the camera does anyone know him oh yeah
yeah he lives around the corner around
the second block down this sixth up
third floor copper say okay so they
arrive in boom boom boom on the door
your man's there I presume kind of
eating a takeaway or something and
copper said we want to bang you off for
the the bank robbery and he said how do
you mean the bank robbery he says no no
we've got you on camera for the bank
robbery we just want to bang you off
here we go he said how how do you mean
you got me for the bank look we got you
for the bank Robie he how but how did
you know he said how could you possibly
know I wore the
juice copper looks at him says what do
you remember when we were kids invisible
Inc
and you put lemon juice on the invisible
ink and you this is a true story and you
disappear your man covered him face with
lemon juice and he thought he was
invisible the overconfident
overestimating their competence now when
the psychologists thought about this
they actually did lots and lots of tests
and it's apparently it's true that this
is a thing in society and surprise
surprise the Dunning Krueger effect is
much more
prevalent in men than women who would
have
known shock horror right I I can see it
in my own family our son for example
comes home teenager after doing an exam
hasn't done a tap of work right comes in
the door and everyone in the family is
the kitchen say how did you do in your
exam right and he he says oh Jesus he
stop man no problem and he fails all the
time all the time so you see these
things and you that that again happens
and of course how this happens in
institutions is you get very
overconfident people very intelligent
can't make mistakes and we saw that in
the
2008 financial crisis 2008 the biggest
financial crisis the world has ever seen
and the vast majority of economists in
the fed the bank of England and the
European Central Bank and Wall Street
missed the whole thing in fact the Queen
of England went to the LSC about two or
3 months after the crash and she said if
you chaps were so clever how come none
of you saw this
coming and she was
right because they all were wearing the
juice the economics
juice right now JK GB very famous
Canadian Economist well galra said
something fascinating about the
conventional person he said when faced
with the choice between changing his
mind and finding the proof not to do so
the conventional man always gets busy
looking for the
proof and that's when we make big
mistakes at these critical moments
Leonard
con the Canadian poet put it differently
the same idea con said there is a
crack in everything and that is how the
light gets
in and what con was saying to us was
look for the cracks look into the cracks
that's where we'll see the big
picture so let's just leave Canadian
poet go back to an Irish
poet the words of the second coming
again our world right now
now turning and turning in the widening
gu the Falcon cannot hear the falconer
Things Fall Apart the center cannot hold
mere Anarchy is loosed on the world a
blood dimmed tide is loosed and
everywhere the procession of innocence
is drowned and why says Yates because
the best lack all conviction and the
worst are full
of passionate
intensity now apply that to our world
and if you at this Tipping Point say n
you know it's it's not my problem I lack
all
conviction right I go and watch baseball
or rounders or whatever that game is you
guys watched right but if you lack all
conviction what actually happens is the
worst people in our
society with their passionate intensity
their certitude their simple ideas they
will win the day at this Tipping Point
and they will win the day because the
best people back away from the
responsibility what y Yates was also
saying about the best people was the
following he was saying mandate the
best The Poets the
artists the
musicians because they are the people
who see the
possibilities they see the possibilities
because they see the world from a
different angle they have to be part of
the
solution so my my idea that I think is
worth spreading is the
following if you want to understand the
world a little bit more clearly listen
less to My Tribe the economists and
listen listen more to yates's tribe The
Poets thank you very
much thank
you thank you thank you very
much